- Hi, Peanut.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh, Kelly Clarkson!
- How are you?
- This is the greatest thing ever.
I have to tell you, I've been
wanting to come on the show.
Hi, it's good to see you too, Beth.
- Hi, Peanut.
- Good to see you, nice to meet you.
Fine, good to see you.
But Kelly!
I wanted to come on your show.
I've been watching your
show (mumbles) forever.
You are so great!
- Oh my god, thank you.
- And the show is fantastic
and I'm the biggest fan.
Has anyone ever said
they're your biggest fan?
- Yes.
- They are liars!
(audience laughing)
It is me.
I am telling you.
I've loved you since, it's
been what, 17 years now?
- [Kelly] 17 years.
- 17 years.
Oh my gosh, it was so great.
And then you're standing there and you won
and everyone's crying and
the confetti's coming down.
You know, it was way too much (mumbles).
Too much confetti.
But you're crying and
you still had to sing.
And Justin, he's pretending
that he didn't care that he lost.
(audience laughing)
[Peanut] I know, it was great.
It was fantastic, I've
been a fan ever since.
You've reinvented
yourself a couple of times
and now you have your own talk show!
- Thank you!
(audience clapping)
I loved talking, Peanut.
All right.